rocket money says that Bezos subscribes
to instant Ramen of the month club Ramen
of the month you know this Ramen yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's
noodles yes yeah Ramen is is noodles
yeah yeah okay now we know this guy
spend like a
78,000 a month on noodles Jesus chicken
beef spicy shrimp veggie chocolate
they're so stupid
you don't know where this [__] comes
from so I canceled this I subscribed him
instead to a home anima kit of the month
club that way he can wash out his bum
from all of these noodles and if he gets
sh on the enema nozzle or whatever he
gets the new enema kit every single
month you welcome Jeff Bezos okay